This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Metaphorical anecdote coming in 3, 2, 1. Years ago we were asked to do a re-asign for a school. A school that will remain anonymous. It was for their sports program. They needed a new mascot. That's Christopher Simmons. My name is Christopher Simmons. I am the principal and creative director of the design firm mine in San Francisco. He also teaches identity design at the California College of the Arts. We've created several alternatives. A few new mascots.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。寓意深刻的轶事将在 3、2、1 后登场。多年前，有人请我们为一所学校重新设计标志。一所将保持匿名的学校。这是为他们的体育项目做的。他们需要一个新的吉祥物。那是克里斯托弗·西蒙斯（Christopher Simmons）。我叫克里斯托弗·西蒙斯。我是旧金山设计公司 mine 的负责人兼创意总监。他还在加州艺术学院教授标志设计。我们制作了几个备选方案。几个新的吉祥物。
To show that to the steering committee, they had their favorite, but they were unsure. They wanted buy-in from the student body and alums. Seem reasonable, but also treacherous territory. So they got like 600 something responses and overwhelmingly, by right and vote, the original logo was the favorite. Not surprising. Change is often the hardest of all possible options. And people would argue, well, you know, that's everyone feels maybe we shouldn't change it. But there was a real problem with the old mascot.
为了向指导委员会展示，他们有最喜欢的一个，但拿不定主意。他们希望获得学生群体和校友的支持。这看起来很合理，但也是个充满风险的领域。于是他们收到了大约 600 多条反馈，绝大多数人通过投票选出了原来的标志。这并不奇怪。改变往往是所有可能选项中最难的。有人可能会争辩说，好吧，你知道，也许大家都觉得我们不该改变。但旧吉祥物确实存在一个真正的问题。
The problem was, they were using their original logo illegally. It was actually the University of Notre Dame's logo and the reason they engaged us to change it was because they realized they did not have the right to do that. Of course the constituency of the school, all the people who loved the original logo didn't know anything about that. They didn't know the reason why they're needed to be a new logo. But the public dialogue continued. Then of course people wanted to be constructive with their criticism. So they said, well, the reasons we don't like the new one, if we had to pick up a new one, why is it a white person, right? We're a diverse school so it should be maybe more ethnically ambiguous. Why is it a male?
问题在于，他们一直在非法使用原来的标志。它实际上是圣母大学的标志，他们请我们去修改的原因是他们意识到自己没有这样做的权利。当然，学校的选民，所有热爱原标志的人对此一无所知。他们不知道为什么需要一个新标志。但公众的对话仍在继续。接着，人们自然希望给出建设性的批评。所以他们说，好吧，我们不喜欢新标志的原因是，如果我们必须挑选一个新标志的话，为什么是个白人？我们是一所多元化的学校，所以它也许应该在族裔上更模糊一些。为什么是个男性？
We're co-ed, so maybe it could be more androgynous. He's so aggressive. I know it's a sports program, but you know, we're a Catholic school. Could you make it less violent? And so they wanted a ethnically ambiguous androgynous non-violent mascot, and they're the fighting Irish. There are factors at play that guide a design of which not everyone is aware.
我们是男女同校，所以也许它可以更雌雄同体。他太咄咄逼人了。我知道这是一个体育项目，但你知道，我们是一所天主教学校。你能把它设计得不那么暴力吗？因此，他们想要一个族裔模糊、雌雄同体且非暴力的吉祥物，而他们却是“战斗爱尔兰人队”（fighting Irish）。在指导设计的过程中，存在着并非每个人都了解的各种因素。
But that doesn't stop everyone from having an opinion. And I like people having opinions about design. I think a design awareness is at an all-time high, and this has by and large help designers of all kinds. People have cotton dawned on to the idea that their interaction with the built world and their hidden communication with the people who designed it really matters. It's really important. And like I said, this usually works out pretty well, but sometimes it's a f***ing train wreck.
但这并不妨碍每个人都发表意见。我喜欢人们对设计有看法。我认为人们对设计的意识达到了历史最高点，这在很大程度上帮助了各种各样的设计师。人们已经开始意识到，他们与人工建造的世界的互动，以及他们与设计者的隐秘交流真的很重要。这真的非常重要。就像我说的，这通常进展得相当顺利，但有时却是一场该死的灾难。
This is the biography of a logo, the brief and tumultuous life of the new logo of the University of California. So if you're not from California or miss this bit of news, the University of California has a new logo, kinda, or rather, had a new logo. And to be more precise, they had a new visual identity system, which is the kind of entirely accurate but completely wonky description that gets met with sarcastic eye rolls from anyone who isn't a designer, but there it is. But they don't have a new logo anymore, because of a massive public backlash. The UC system actually suspended the new monogram logo, while we were reporting this story.
这是一个标志的传记，是加州大学新标志短暂而动荡的一生。所以，如果你不是来自加州，或者错过了这条新闻，加州大学换了一个新标志，算是吧，或者更准确地说，曾拥有一个新标志。更精确一点讲，他们拥有了一个新的视觉识别系统，这种描述绝对准确却又极其学究气，非设计师听到只会报以讽刺的白眼，但事实就是如此。不过，由于遭到大规模的公众强烈反对，他们不再拥有这个新标志了。在我们报道这个故事的同时，加州大学系统实际上已经暂停了新的字母组合标志。
And the creative director of the UC office of the president is not happy about how it turned out. I would say that it was the use of the rhetoric of democracy for the tyranny of the minority. That's Vanessa Corea. We'll hear more from her in a minute. And the fellow you heard before her, it's the ruse far of our. He's been on the show before,
加州大学校长办公室的创意总监对这个结果很不满意。我想说的是，这是用民主的修辞行少数人之暴政。那是凡妮莎·科雷亚（Vanessa Corea）。我们一会儿会听到她更多的发言。在她之前发言的那位仁兄，是西鲁斯·法瓦拉（Sirouse Farvara）。他以前也上过这个节目，
having reported about Bond, Germany, and amazing Belgian beer. But now he's back home here in the Golden State of California. Alright, so before we get to why people hated this new logo, we need to tell you what it looked like first. It looks a little like a shield with a mostly flat top and a rounded bottom. Supermphosed on the shield is the letter C. And when it was first presented, the shield was in blue and the C was in gold. These are the historic colors of the university system. But it was designed to be extremely versatile and almost any color. So just to be clear, this was the new symbol for the entire UC system as a whole. Not just UC Berkeley or UCLA or UC San Diego, all ten campuses. So one of the reasons the public backlash surprised the in-house team that designed this logo,
曾报道过德国波恩以及令人惊叹的比利时啤酒。但现在他回到了加州这个黄金之州的老家。好了，在我们探讨为什么人们讨厌这个新标志之前，我们需要先告诉你它长什么样。它看起来有点像一个盾牌，顶部基本平坦，底部呈圆弧形。盾牌上叠加了一个字母 C。刚推出时，盾牌是蓝色的，字母 C 是金色的。这些是该大学系统的历史颜色。但它的设计极具多功能性，几乎能适应任何颜色。所以需要澄清的是，这是整个加州大学系统的全新标志。不只是伯克利分校、洛杉矶分校或圣迭戈分校，而是全部十个校区。因此，公众的强烈反对之所以让设计这个标志的内部团队感到意外，
and it's a company and color scheme and associated icons, is that it's all been around for nearly a year. It was part of a massive on-word California public marketing campaign to build awareness of the university system as part of what makes California great. Yeah, in fact, they took it on tour to all 10 campuses, where they drove around a build awareness of the university system as part of what makes California great. Yeah, in fact, they took it on tour to all 10 campuses, where they drove around a huge truck with the logo and all the new colors and everything around to show it to the faculty and students, and no one said a word.
以及它的一家公司、配色方案和相关图标，是因为这一切都已经存在了近一年。这是加州轰轰烈烈的公共营销活动的一部分，旨在建立对大学系统的认知，将其作为让加州伟大的因素之一。是的，事实上，他们带着它巡回了所有 10 个校区，在那里他们开着一辆，旨在建立对大学系统的认知，将其作为让加州伟大的因素之一。是的，事实上，他们带着一个印有标志、新颜色和各种元素的巨大卡车进行了全校巡回，向教职员工和学生展示，结果竟然没有人说一句话。
The design team at the UC office of the president probably thought they'd done a good job and they were ready to move forward. Then in early December, these shields like UC Monogram hit the blocks. And two things happened that set the stage for the burning towards reaction that it got from the public beyond the aesthetic opinions. I do recognize that there are completely valid criticisms that could be made about the design itself, but this first error on the part of the press really doomed it out of the gate. There were lots of articles in the media, nearly all of them actually,
加州大学校长办公室的设计团队可能认为他们做得很好，并准备继续推进。然后在 12 月初，这些类似于加州大学字母组合的盾牌标志出现在了各大平台上。有两件事为公众除了审美观点之外的愤怒反应奠定了基础。我确实承认，针对设计本身可以提出完全合理的批评，但媒体方面的第一个失误确实让它从一开始就注定了失败。媒体上有很多文章，实际上几乎全部文章，
that put the classic university seal side by side with the new UC logo. It sort of strongly implied, I think, to most people, and reasonably so, that the seal was the before and the monogram was after. That's Christopher Simmons again, who you heard from at the very top of the show. He had nothing to do with this UC logo redesigned but he waited into the fray with a blog post on his own website called Why the UC Rebrand is Better Than You Think.
都将传统的大学校徽与新的加州大学标志并排放在一起。我认为，这给大多数人一种强烈暗示，而且这种暗示是合理的：即校徽是“过去”，字母组合是“现在”。再次听到的是克里斯托弗·西蒙斯，你在节目最开始听过他的声音。他和这次加州大学标志的重新设计没有任何关系，但他自己在网站上发表了一篇名为《为什么加州大学的品牌重塑比你想象的要好》的博客文章，从而卷入了这场纷争。
And that therefore the monogram would be replacing the seal. And of course that wasn't the case. It sort of framed the conversation completely wrong. The second misstep, and this one actually got to me as a UC Berkeley graduate, was that the UC Office of the President released a video online that showed the graphical evolution from the old seal to the new logo. Which was produced by the University of California to kind of show some of the thinking behind the genesis of the new monogram, and how it related to the seal, how it sort of took some
因此这就意味着字母组合将取代校徽。当然事实并非如此。这在很大程度上完全误导了对话的方向。第二个失误——作为一个加州大学伯克利分校的毕业生，这个失误真的戳中了我的痛点——是加州大学校长办公室在网上发布了一段视频，展示了从旧校徽到新标志的图形演变过程。这段视频由加州大学制作，旨在展示新字母组合诞生背后的部分思考过程，以及它与校徽的关系，它是如何借鉴校徽的某些
of its cues from it. In the video, hands-pulled design elements from the seal to create the new design and literally sweep aside the old seal, brushing it away and tossing it out. The video reinforced everyone's greatest fear about the new brand. So those two things were working against it from the get-go.
特点的。在视频中，有手从校徽中拉出设计元素来创作新设计，并字面意义上地扫除旧校徽，将其刷掉并抛弃。这段视频放大了每个人对新品牌最深层的恐惧。因此，从一开始就有这两件事在对它产生不利影响。
And the fact that this was all new and changes understandably very hard and as a university logo it was really standing out all on its own. It's really easy to criticize. The UC alumni and the California public at large sought and the reaction was really negative. Roman, that is actually an understatement. A lot of people felt that this new logo was too modern, too cheap, and really denigrated the gravitas, and that was the word that was used,
再加上这一切都是全新的，而且改变本身就很难，作为一所大学的标志，它确实非常显眼。这真的很容易招致批评。加州大学的校友和加州广大公众看到了它，反应非常负面。罗曼，这其实还是保守的说法。很多人觉得这个新标志太现代、太廉价，并且严重贬低了大学的尊严，这是当时用的一个词，
the gravitas of the university. In fact, Lieutenant Governor Gavin Newsom, the former mayor of San Francisco, sent an angry letter on December 11th to the UC president. Quote, the overwhelmingly negative response to the recent change to the UC president, quote, the overwhelmingly negative response to the recent change to the University of California logo demands immediate attention.
即大学的庄严感。事实上，前旧金山市长、副州长加文·纽森（Gavin Newsom）在 12 月 11 日给加州大学校长写了一封愤怒的信。原话是：“对加州大学标志近期变动的压倒性负面反应，原话是：‘对加州大学标志近期变动的压倒性负面反应，需要立即引起重视。’”
He went on, perhaps now it is time to return to the use of the old logo and allowed the university community a cooling off period to concentrate on the long term health of the university. Instead of being creative with the University of California logo, which would be searching for creative solutions for funding the University of California. He's wrong because the logo, there is no logo to restore. There was no old logo, and again, it's a classic case of the misinformation reaching the very, very top.
他接着说：“也许现在是时候恢复使用旧标志，并给大学社区一段冷静期，以专注于大学的长期发展。与其在加州大学的标志上发挥创意，不如去寻找为加州大学筹集资金的创造性解决方案。”他是错的，因为根本没有旧标志可以恢复。根本没有旧标志，再次说明，这是一个典型的 misinformation（虚假信息）传到最高层的案例。
That's Vanessa Kareya, the creative director of the UC Office of the President. Vanessa led the team that came up with this logo in the new visual brand. She says that a lot of the negative reaction was because the media implied that the classic seal was being replaced. But there were no such plans. The seal which the UC has reassured everyone will stay on diplomas is more of a classic collegiate icon. It's circular with the words seal of the University of California around the edge, an image of an open book and the motto let there be light at the bottom. An earlier version of the seal dates back to when the university was founded in the 19th century. In its current form, that seal has been unchanged since 1910.
那是加州大学校长办公室的创意总监凡妮莎·加雷亚（Vanessa Kareya）。凡妮莎领导了设计这个标志和新视觉品牌的团队。她说，许多负面反应是因为媒体暗示经典的校徽将被取代。但根本没有这样的计划。加州大学已向所有人保证将继续保留在毕业证书上的校徽，更像是一个经典的大学图标。它是圆形的，边缘环绕着“加州大学之印”（seal of the University of California）字样，底部是一本翻开的书的图案以及座右铭“让光明普照”（let there be light）。该校徽的早期版本可以追溯到 19 世纪大学建校之时。以目前的形式，这个校徽自 1910 年以来就一直没有变过。
So UC Berkeley, my alma mater, has the UC seal on its official communications. It's what's on my diploma. It was on my aunts, my grandparents, and yes, in its earlier form, it was on my great-grandparents' diplomas. I am the fourth generation in a line of UC Berkeley graduates. But more casual logos do exist, like the CalScript logo that's on the UC Berkeley football helmet. And every 10th person sweatshirt and downtown Berkeley. Or the C. BearClaw logo that's on a baseball cap that I own. So Cal and UCLA and lots of other universities
所以加州大学伯克利分校，我的母校，在其官方通讯中使用加州大学校徽。它就印在我的毕业证书上。它也印在我阿姨、祖父母的证书上，是的，以其早期形式，它还印在我曾祖父母的毕业证书上。我是加州大学伯克利分校毕业生家族的第四代。但也有一些更随意的标志存在，比如印在加州大学伯克利分校橄榄球头盔上的 CalScript 标志。以及每十个人中就有一个人的运动衫和伯克利市中心都能看到的标志。或者是我拥有的棒球帽上的 C. BearClaw 标志。所以加州大学伯克利分校和洛杉矶分校以及许多其他大学
have this distinctiveness between a more official seal and a more casual logo, but the UC system as a whole did not. The seal for all the good things that it does represent can't carry all of that symbolic weight. Why not? Because it's already interacting in a sort of rhetorical space that is much more institutional. Like it's too stuffy. You can say that if you want, but... Is that sort of how you feel about it? feel about it? I actually think that the seal is fantastic because when we need to have the weight,
在更正式的校徽和更随意的标志之间有着这种独特性，但整个加州大学系统却没有。校徽无论代表了多少美好的事物，也无法承载所有这些象征性的分量。为什么不呢？因为它已经在一个更加机构化的修辞空间中互动了。比如它太古板了。如果你想这么说，你可以这么说，但是……你是不是就是这么觉得的？你对此有什么感觉？我其实觉得校徽太棒了，因为当我们需要在预算书背后，或者在校长宣言背后，或者诸如此类的事情背后，调动大学的分量、
the full weight, and gravitas of the university behind a budget book, or behind a proclamation by the president, or whatever that is, that seal gives us that gravitas. But we don't always want that gravitas. That gravitas has a place in communication. It's like having a tuxedo and being forced to wear it every single day. In other words, what the team of designers at UC intended to do was to create an icon
全部分量和庄严感时，那个校徽就能赋予我们这种庄严感。但我们并不总是想要这种庄严感。这种庄严感在交流中有它的位置。这就像有一套燕尾服，却被迫每天都穿它一样。换句话说，加州大学的设计团队想要做的是创造一个图标，
that could be used as part of a broader campaign to more dynamically and more casually explain the university system to people. Korea explained that the logo would never stand on its own as it was depicted in media reports. It would almost always be presented with the words University of California next to it, or the motto, let there be light. It would have all these other visual cues that would help you see, sell itself. You talked about expressing dynamism and light and these sorts of things. Do you feel like that the logo should be able to stand on its own? I mean, I think that, again, for me, I feel like when I look at this and you say,
它可以作为更广泛宣传活动的一部分，用来更动态、更随意地向人们解释大学系统。科雷亚解释说，这个标志绝不会像媒体报道中那样孤立地存在。它几乎总是与“加州大学”（University of California）字样或座右铭“让光明普照”（let there be light）一起出现。它将拥有所有这些其他的视觉线索，帮助你理解并接受这个标志本身。你谈到了表达活力、光明和诸如此类的事情。你觉得这个标志应该能够独立存在吗？我的意思是，我认为，再次说明，对我而言，我觉得当我看到这个，然后你说，
well, you know, it's part of a larger thing. There's text that goes with it. There's other contextual information that would help me to understand what it is. Because when I just see it, this does not scream to me, you see. Like, I don't- What's that? Today it doesn't, but it will. Okay. So, you know, you need the ecosystem to build the meaning into the object.
嗯，你知道，这是更大系统的一部分。有与之配套的文字。还有其他上下文信息可以帮助我理解它是什么。因为当我只看到它时，这并没有对我大喊“我是加州大学”。就像，我没有——什么？今天它没有，但以后会有。好吧。所以，你知道，你需要整个生态系统来将意义构建到这个客体中。
You need people to begin to identify it with the good works of the university for them to... You build the meaning. A logo on itself is nothing. It's just a...it's a thing. You know, you...a logo doesn't come fully formed with the meaning baked in. The meaning is accrued over time. The Nike swoosh looks like a giant chat mark. I mean, if people had social media insight into it today, they would say, why is it only one? Why is it so plain? Why is it look like a check? You know, is that supposed to be a wing?
你需要人们开始将它与大学的优良工作联系起来，以便让他们……你来构建意义。一个标志本身什么都不是。它只是一个……它是个东西。你知道，你……一个标志不会凭空带着内涵完全成型。意义是随着时间积累出来的。耐克（Nike）的勾形标志看起来像一个巨大的对勾符号。我的意思是，如果人们今天用社交媒体的眼光来看待它，他们会说，为什么只有一个？为什么这么朴素？为什么看起来像个对勾？你知道，这难道应该是一只翅膀吗？
I don't get it. I don't see a wing. You know, the meaning has accrued through years of quality products or non-quality products and athletes associating with it and the interaction that you have with the brand writ large. The same thing for Apple. Can you imagine?
我不明白。我看不到翅膀。你知道，它的意义是通过多年的优质产品（或非优质产品）、运动员与它的关联，以及你与这个宏观品牌的互动而积累起来的。苹果公司也是如此。你能想象吗？
I mean, it's an Apple. This is a computer company. Why do you have an Apple? Is this a grocery store? I don't understand. It's the same kind of thing. The meaning is not baked in. You build the meaning.
我的意思是，它是一个苹果。这是一家电脑公司。你为什么用一个苹果？这是杂货店吗？我不明白。道理是一样的。意义不是一开始就内置的。你需要建立意义。
That's what building a brand is. People's emotional resonance with something develops over time. The only reason why it's a ruse and so many other UC alums have such a strong bond with the seal is because it's been around for over a century. And that bond is further strengthened by every other seal in the world. They're really not all that distinct.
这就是打造品牌的过程。人们对某种事物的共鸣是随着时间推移而发展的。西鲁斯和许多其他加州大学校友对校徽有如此深厚的情感联系，唯一的全因是它已经存在了一个多世纪。而这种联系又因世界上所有其他校徽而进一步加固。它们其实并没有那么独特。
Seals now kind of naturally communicate a history and tradition, and indeed, gravitas. Vanessa says she gets all that. And while she herself may have attended another UC, that would be the University of Cincinnati, she thinks that part of why there's been so much negative attention toward the logo is because it's become a lightning rod for other issues.
现在的校徽自然地传达了一种历史和传统，以及庄严感。凡妮莎说她完全理解这一点。虽然她自己上的可能是另一所加州大学（University of Cincinnati，译注：辛辛那提大学缩写也为UC，此处为双关或口误），但她认为，之所以有这么多针对该标志的负面关注，部分原因在于它成了其他问题的出气筒。
I think that there are other things going on here in the outcry. Part of what's going on is that this has become a very simple way to express a lot of other frustrations about the university. I mean, I've received that from a lot of different people. They are frustrated because they feel like the administration is inaccessible. They're frustrated because their tuition's going up. They're frustrated for all these things. They're frustrated about the privatization of the university.
我认为这次的抗议背后还有其他事情在起作用。部分原因在于，这成了一种表达对大学其他各种不满情绪的非常简单的方式。我的意思是，我从许多不同的人那里收到了这样的反馈。他们感到沮丧，是因为他们觉得管理层高高在上、难以接近。他们感到沮丧，是因为学费在上涨。他们因为所有这些事情而感到沮丧。他们对大学的私有化感到沮丧。
Rightly so. I'm frustrated too. That's part of the reason why I'm sitting here trying to get people to actually care about it because I want them to go and vote for it. But now that we've described the purpose of the logo and the uphill climb it had ahead of it, I think it's fair to talk about the actual graphic design that a lot of people, both the lay public and several designers, had huge problems with. One common complaint was the fact that the C part of the design wasn't totally solid. It was a gradient. The bottom part of
这是理所当然的。我也感到沮丧。这也是我坐在这里试图让人们真正关心这件事的部分原因，因为我希望他们去为之投票。但既然我们已经阐述了该标志的目的以及它面临的艰难历程，我认为我们有必要讨论一下实际的平面设计，许多普通公众和几位设计师都对这个设计有着巨大的意见。一个常见的抱怨是，设计中的 C 部分不是完全实心的。它是一个渐变色。底部的
the C was lighter than the top. And while the intention was to convey movement and luminosity, that's not what a lot of people saw in it. The first time I saw the logo, I immediately thought of a computer icon of something loading. I spent a lot of time in front of my computer. Maybe you do too. This C looks exactly like a circle,
C 比顶部要浅。虽然其初衷是传达运动感和发光感，但这并不是许多人从中所看到的。我第一次看到这个标志时，立刻联想到了电脑上表示正在加载的图标。我在电脑前花了很多时间。也许你也是。这个 C 看起来就像一个圆圈，
indicating a loading browser tab or Skype opening or any other number of loading scenarios on a computer. Vanessa told me that this was pure coincidence and she expressed a little bit of regret over it. This particular color combination is one that really pops out that loader bar reference in a way that is again, I mean, very unfortunate. On the UC website where the identity was introduced, you could actually see other versions of the logo with different colors.
暗示着正在加载的浏览器标签页、正在打开的 Skype 或计算机上的其他各种加载场景。凡妮莎告诉我，这纯属巧合，她对此表达了一点遗憾。这种特定的颜色组合确实非常突兀地让人联想到加载条，从某种角度来说，确实非常不幸。在介绍该视觉识别系统的加州大学官网上，其实可以看到该标志采用其他颜色的版本。
They were black and white and blue and white versions of the monogram that didn't have a gradient at all. I personally preferred those, but I don't think those were very widely seen. Vanessa also told me that what's gotten drowned out in all the noise of journalists like me wanting to talk to her is the fact that people in the design world do like it. There was an op-ed written in the San Francisco Chronicle by Rob Duncan, formerly of Pentagram. He's now an art director at Apple, and he also runs his own design shop in San Francisco. He called the new UC logo, quote, one of the freshest and most creative education identity schemes in a country full of boring institutional logos. But the much more common and widely publicized response was very, very negative. An online petition called Stop the New UC logo received over 54,000 signatures, and
它们是黑白版和蓝白版的字母组合，根本没有渐变效果。我个人更喜欢那些版本，但我认为它们并没有被广泛看到。凡妮莎还告诉我，在像我这样想要采访她的记者们的各种喧嚣声中，被淹没的事实是：设计界的人其实很喜欢它。前五角设计联盟（Pentagram）成员罗布·邓肯（Rob Duncan）在《旧金山纪事报》上撰写了一篇专栏文章。他现在是苹果公司的艺术总监，同时也在旧金山经营自己的设计工作室。他称这个新的加州大学标志是“在充满无聊机构标志的国家中，最新鲜、最有创意的教育识别方案之一”。但更常见、更广为人知的反应是非常非常负面的。一个名为“停止使用新加州大学标志”的网络请愿书获得了超过 54,000 个签名，并且
as we alluded to earlier, on December 14, there's a few days into the extremely vociferous public reaction to the logo. The UC director of marketing communications released a statement saying that the new UC monogram was being shelved. Quote, in the past week, it has become clear that the University of California's system-wide monogram recently created is a source for great debate, dialogue, and division. In short, it's too much of a distraction from our broader effort to communicate UC's value and vital contributions to Californians. So we intend to suspend use of the new monograms. We will begin to take steps required to do so. I certainly had an initial negative reaction to the monogram when I first saw it too.
正如我们前面提到的，在 12 月 14 日，也就是公众对该标志的强烈反对持续了几天的几天后，加州大学营销传讯总监发表声明称，新的加州大学字母组合已被搁置。原话是：“在过去的一周里，很明显，最近创建的加州大学全系统字母组合引发了巨大的争论、对话和分歧。简而言之，它分散了我们向加州人传达加州大学价值和重要贡献这一更广泛工作的注意力。因此，我们打算暂停使用新字母组合。我们将开始采取所需的步骤来做到这一点。”我第一次看到这个字母组合时，最初确实也有负面反应。
I still think the gradient is just not quite right, but overall, after talking to Vanessa, even a skeptic like me is a little bit more convinced of its usefulness and of its quality. You don't have to like design to recognize that it's good design. I don't like Led Zeppelin. Don't say anything about it. I don't like Led Zeppelin.
我仍然认为渐变效果有点不太对劲，但总体而言，在与凡妮莎交谈后，像我这样的怀疑论者也对它的实用性和质量有了一点更多信服。你不需要喜欢设计也能认出什么是好设计。我不喜欢齐柏林飞艇乐队（Led Zeppelin）。什么都别说。我不喜欢齐柏林飞艇乐队。
I have no opinion on Led Zeppelin one way or another. I don't like Led Zeppelin, but I understand what they've done and why people think they're good and why they are good and where they fit into rock and roll history. Like, it's fine not to like it, but you need to understand what it's trying to do, and to go from there, you know, I would say, I hate the IBM logo, but it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
我对齐柏林飞艇乐队没有任何倾向性的看法。我不喜欢齐柏林飞艇乐队，但我理解他们所做的一切，理解为什么人们认为他们很优秀、为什么他们确实优秀，以及他们在摇滚乐历史中处于什么位置。就像，不喜欢它是可以的，但你需要理解它试图做什么，并在此基础上发展，你知道，我想说，我讨厌 IBM 的标志，但这没关系。这没关系。
It does what it needs to do. And so from that perspective, I would say, you know, I would hope that people think about design, and the way that one should be thinking about design, rather than assuming that purely subjective response to one thing badly posted on a internet platform is is enough to base an entire judgment on. I talked to my 91-year-old grandfather about the new UC logo 2. He graduated from Calvin in the 1940s and he said he didn't like it either. For many of the same reasons that we talked about earlier, that it wasn't clear what it was supposed to represent, that
它完成了它需要做的事。所以从这个角度来看，我想说，你知道，我希望人们思考设计，并且应该以正确的方式思考设计，而不是仅仅因为互联网平台上某个被糟糕发布的单一条目的主观反应，就足以作为做出整体判断的依据。我也和我的 91 岁祖父聊过加州大学的新标志。他在 20 世纪 40 年代毕业于加尔文大学，他说他也不喜欢它。原因和我们之前讨论的许多原因一样：它不清楚代表什么，而且
the sea in UC looked weird. And when I explained what Vanessa had told me, he chewed on that for a while, but ultimately I think came away unconvinced. For Korea and many designers who have spoken out in support of her and her team's efforts, they continue to say that their work was bold, daring, and does represent modern California. Here again is Christopher Simmons. I think the role of an expert, and an expert to me is just someone who is trained in a particular field and has some, perhaps, or hopefully, deep experience in the practice of that field, is to see the world through a different lens. So, for example, when we had our kitchen renovated here, I don't know anything about architecture,
加州大学标志中的字母 C 看起来很奇怪。当我向他解释凡妮莎告诉我的内容时，他琢磨了一会儿，但最终我想他还是觉得无法信服。对于科雷亚以及许多公开支持她及其团队努力的设计师来说，他们仍然坚持认为他们的工作是大胆的、勇敢的，并且确实代表了现代加州。再次有请克里斯托弗·西蒙斯。我认为专家的角色——对我来说，专家只是在某个特定领域受过培训，并且在该领域的实践中有一些、或者希望是深厚经验的人——就是通过不同的镜头看世界。例如，当我们这里翻新厨房时，我对建筑一无所知，
I don't know anything about engineering, I don't know anything about really about interior design. I have my opinions, but that's all they are. And so, when a designer tells me why I think this would work best, I defer to that opinion. When a mechanic tells me that this thing needs to be fixed on my car, I trust that he or she is active with that. When I go to my doctor, they're telling me how to understand my own body, and I don't know how to interpret what's happening to my body, so I allow them to do that for me.
我对工程一无所知，对室内设计也几乎一无所知。我有我的意见，但也仅此而已。所以，当设计师告诉我为什么我认为这样效果最好时，我尊重这种意见。当机械师告诉我我的车的这个部件需要修理时，我信任他或她在专业上的行动。当我去见医生时，他们在教我如何理解我自己的身体，而我不知道如何解释我身体发生的事情，所以我允许他们为我做这件事。
When it comes to design, we don't seem culturally to have that same trust. And so, perhaps saying that people are ignorant of design or not knowledgeable of the process or short-sighted is contentious, it's probably strictly speaking true, but it's not always wise to say the true thing in exactly the way you're thinking it. We live in a time when everyone feels that their opinion matters. And the reality is, is that not all opinions are equal. That's not popular because you like to think that your voice is the same as someone else's. But when it comes to, for example, physics, my voice is not the same as Stephen Hawkins.
但在设计方面，我们在文化上似乎没有那种信任。所以，也许说人们对设计无知、或对过程不了解、或目光短浅是有争议的，严格来说可能是真的，但以你脑海中想到的那种方式把真话说出来并不总是明智的。我们生活在一个每个人都觉得自己的意见很重要的时代。但现实是，并非所有意见都是平等的。这并不受欢迎，因为你喜欢认为自己的声音和别人的一样。但例如在物理学方面，我的声音就和斯蒂芬·霍金（Stephen Hawking）不一样。
Nor should it be. Aesthetics is a very easy target because everyone, no one understands how aesthetics works, and they feel that subjective opinion is the rule of the day. I don't like it, therefore it must not be good. So, I get that. No one wants to be told how to do their job by rank amateurs who don't understand what they're trying to do. I don't go to restaurants and tell chefs that their pizza could use more basil in the tomato sauce, but the difference between designers like Vanessa and the physics world
它本该如此。美学是一个非常容易攻击的目标，因为每个人、没有人理解美学是如何运作的，他们觉得主观意见就是王道。我不喜欢它，所以它一定不好。所以，我懂。没有人愿意听那些根本不明白他们在做什么的业余门外汉对他们的工作指手画脚。我不会去餐馆告诉厨师他们的番茄酱里罗勒可以再多放一点，但是像凡妮莎这样的设计师与物理学界的区别在于，
is that we, the public, are not invited to sit in Stephen Hawking's physics lab in Cambridge. We're not part of that world, period. But design in general, and this design in particular, is about communication and interaction with a public who are completely unaware of the motivations behind a certain design. The logo isn't meant to sit in someone's sketchbook. It's meant to be out there in the world, telling the story of the University of California. And right or wrong, the people connected to the university still feel like they have a say in the matter. It's hard to say what the ultimate effect of this whole fiasco will be. I think institutions like the University of California, which tend to be pretty change-averse anyway, will be more gondoshai about pushing new designs and new ideas forward.
我们公众并没有被邀请坐在斯蒂芬·霍金在剑桥的物理实验室里。我们不属于那个世界，句号。但一般的设计，尤其是这个设计，关乎的是与完全不了解某种设计背后的动机的公众的沟通和互动。这个标志并不是为了放在某人的素描本里而设计的。它是为了存在于现实世界中，讲述加州大学的故事。无论对错，与这所大学有关的人仍然觉得他们在这件事上有发言权。很难说这场闹剧的最终结果会是什么。我认为像加州大学这样的机构，本来就相当反感改变，在推动新设计和新想法时会更加谨慎。
There will be a chilling effect. If that comes to pass, that will be a real shame. I hope the people who really dislike the logo, at least the thoughtful ones, would also not want to see that happen. But I also don't want designers to circle the wagons and claim that no design can be criticized unless the person with an opinion knows the full backstory of the design process. That just seems false and incongruous with reality. I didn't see people making the same defense of the new Gap logo with the little blue square
这会产生一种寒蝉效应。如果真的发生这种情况，那将是一个真正的遗憾。我希望那些非常不喜欢这个标志的人，至少是那些有思想的人，也不希望看到这种情况发生。但我也希望设计师们不要抱团防守，并声称任何设计都不容批判，除非发表意见的人了解设计过程的全部背景故事。这听起来很不真实，也与现实不符。当 Gap 在 2010 年短暂出现带有小蓝方的微调新标志时，
that appeared briefly in 2010. It was derided by everyone, everywhere. Even Christopher Simmons, who has very thoughtfully considered and spoken out against the overreaction to the UC logo, took some swings at the Gap logo back then. Someone made some, you know, jerky website where you could turn anything into the Gap logo to kind of emphasize how generic it was. And so, for a while, my Facebook profile image
我并没有看到人们为之进行同样的辩护。它遭到了所有人、在所有地方的嘲笑。甚至连克里斯托弗·西蒙斯——他曾非常深思熟虑地考虑并公开反对对加州大学标志的过度反应——当年也对 Gap 的标志进行过抨击。有人做了一些，你知道，无聊的网站，你可以把任何东西变成 Gap 的标志，以此来强调它是多么平庸。所以，有一段时间，我的 Facebook 个人资料图片
was, you know, my name with the little blue square in the top right corner. And, you know, in retrospect, that was probably mean. And, you know, I think I take it back. I would. I think it speaks well of his character that Christopher regrets that, but I don't know if he should.
就是，你知道，我的名字加上右上角的小蓝方块。而且，回想起来，这可能有点刻薄。而且，你知道，我想我收回它。我会的。我认为克里斯托弗对此感到后悔说明他人品不错，但我不知道他是否应该后悔。
He cared, any comments, it fundamentally, because these things matter to him. On one level is great that the public is engaged and passionate about design. It's a little dispearing that every time it happens, it's to recall the UC logo, to recall the gap logo, to recall the tropical canapackaging. And we don't see the opposite. We don't see people galvanized around a great new identity that they love.
他在乎，任何评论，本质上是因为这些事情对很重要。从某种程度上说，公众对设计充满热情并参与其中是件好事。令人稍感失望的是，每次发生这种情况，都是为了召回加州大学的标志，召回 Gap 的标志，召回热带罐头包装。而我们没有看到相反的情况。我们没有看到人们为一个他们喜爱的新伟大视觉形象而团结起来。
It's very easy to pile on the hate and the criticism and not offer meaningful alternatives. That said, the fact that design is even being discussed signals that it's important, that it's important to people, that it's important to culture, that it's important to business, and that's a win for everyone. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Sirouse Farvara with help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7, local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco.
一味地堆砌仇恨和批评，却不提供有意义的替代方案，这是非常容易做到的。也就是说，设计甚至正在被讨论这一事实表明它是重要的，它对人们很重要，对文化很重要，对商业很重要，这对每个人来说都是一场胜利。本周的 99% Invisible 由西鲁斯·法瓦拉制作，山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和罗曼·马尔斯协助制作。这是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师协会的项目。
Christopher Simmons, the principal of mine who was featured in this episode, was also interviewed by my hero Debbie Mellman on a recent episode of her Design Matters podcast. I was also featured last season if you want to check that out. You can find Design Matters in iTunes or at Design Observer. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but right now you can look at the UC logo and all kinds of links to all the controversy at 99%invisible.org. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在本期节目中亮相的 mine 负责人克里斯托弗·西蒙斯最近也接受了我的偶像黛比·米尔曼（Debbie Mellman）在其播客节目《设计之重》（Design Matters）最新一期的采访。如果你想去看看的话，我在上一季也出镜过。你可以在 iTunes 或 Design Observer 上找到《设计之重》。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。我在 Twitter 上发推文的账号是 @Roman Mars，但现在你可以在 99%invisible.org 上查看加州大学的标志以及关于所有这些争议的各种链接。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。